[Music]
welcome back so I told you about the
Eckert young theorem which basically
says that if you have a matrix X then
the absolute best rank or approximation
X tilde that you're possibly gonna find
in the Frobenius norm so the Arg min so
the X tilde that minimizes this
expression such that X tilde such that
rank of X tilde equals are the best R
rank matrix X tilde that minimizes this
is given by the are truncated singular
value decomposition this u Sigma V
transpose where essentially we keep just
the first R columns of U and V and the
first r by r sub block of Sigma this is
the truncated singular value
decomposition this is the Eckhart Yong
theorem but I forgot to tell you what
the Frobenius norm is so the Frobenius
norm is really simple if I take the
Frobenius norm of a matrix a essentially
what that is is the square root of the
sum over all I and J of a I J squared
the square root okay that's the
Frobenius norm Frobenius and it's really
simple so the furby Gnaeus norm
essentially is what you get if you take
this matrix a and you reshape it into a
really really really tall n times M by 1
vector this would just be the 2 norm of
that vector so the furby Gnaeus norm of
a matrix is essentially the two norm if
you turn that matrix into a really
really big vector okay and so that's the
the sense in which this is the minimum
norm solution its minimum norm it's the
best rank the SVD gives you the best
rank our approximation X tilde of a
matrix F X in the Frobenius norm ok
thank you